>> It's my great pleasure
to introduce Daniel Selsam.
Daniel is a student,
a PhD candidate at Stanford.
He was interning for
us one and a half
years ago I have been
collaborating with him
for like three years,
in completely different topics.
Last time he visited
us he was using
former methods to verify
Machine Learning algorithms.
And today he is
showing the progress
he made in trying to
learn a SAT Solver,
to have a neuro network
that learns SAT.
>> Thanks Leo. Hi, everybody
thanks for coming today.
I'll be showing you how
to learn an entire SAT
Solving Algorithm from
Single-Bit Supervision.
And this is all joint work with
Leonardo and several others
back at Stanford.
So, as most of you know
neural networks have beaten the
state-of-the-art on
many important problems
just in the last few years.
Most notably object recognition
and speech recognition.
But there have also been
major successes in diverse,
and I think unexpected domains
including machine translation,
social network analysis,
heuristics for board games
like chess and Go,
even predicting
properties of molecules,
optimizing data
center efficiency,
and surprisingly even learning
high-performance
indexing data structures.
And yet we still know
very little about
what neural networks
can and cannot do.
In this work we consider
the following question,
can a Neural Network learn to
perform precise
logical reasoning?
And more specifically, can
a neural network learn
to solve SAT problems?
Here's our setup. We're going
to train a neural network as
a classifier on a data set
of input output pairs,
where the input is
a SAT problem P,
and the output is a Single-Bit
indicating whether or
not P is satisfiable.
At test time we're
going to feed problems
into our trained model
which we call NeuroSAT.
And it's going to predict
as it was trained to do
whether the problems
are satisfaible or not.
As we'll see later in the talk,
it's able to predict
with high accuracy
and when it does
predict satisfiable,
we can almost always
decode an actual solution,
a satisfying assignment from
the internal activations
of the network.
And we'll see how
this works shortly.
For some background on SAT,
I think most of you will be
familiar with this
but just in case.
A propositional formula can be
represented as an AND of ORS.
So here's an example formula,
not X one or X two.
And not X two or X
one, some jargon.
(X one not X one),
(X two not X two) were
all called literals.
And C one and C two are
both called clauses.
Now a formula is satisfiable
if there exists
a satisfying assignment.
So the formula above is
satisfiable because there
exists a satisfying
assignment specifically,
the assignment that maps
X one and X two both to
true satisfies it because
the first clause is satisfied
because X two is true.
And the second clause is
satisfied because X one is true.
And the SAT problem
is given a formula,
determine if it is
satisfiable and if it is,
find a satisfying assignment.
Now, our goal is to
train a neural network
to predict satisfiability
and we're going
to talk about decoding
solutions and actually
solving the problems later on.
And there are two main
design challenges,
what problems do we train on?
And with what kind
of architecture?
Let's talk about
training data first.
So, the issue is that
some problem
distributions might be
arbitrarily easy to classify,
based on superficial properties.
But, a network that's
trained on such a data set
probably will exploit
those properties and
won't generalize and we
won't really have learned
anything semantic about SAT.
So we want to construct
difficult problems to
force it to learn
something general,
to be more systematic about
exploring the SAT problem.
So we define a distribution
that we call SR of N over
problems such that the problems
come in pairs, one unSAT,
one SAT, and they differ
by negating a single
literal and a single clause but
otherwise have
the same statistics.
So, the idea is that
no simple superficial
statistical analysis
will be able to distinguish
between the two.
And specifically
to sample a pair of
problem from SR of N we keep
sampling uniformly
random clauses
until the problem
is unsatisfiable.
At which point we flip a single
literal in the final clause
to make it SAT,
and we return the pair
before and after we
flip that literal.
This distribution
is not guaranteed to
be hard at any complexity
theoretic sense,
but it's intuitively
statistically hard.
For small values of
N it's still easy for
traditional SAT solvers but it
will be very hard for
a standard classifier.
Now let's talk about
Network Architecture.
So we could treat SAT problems
as character strings.
>> You said this are Clauses?
>> Yeah.
>> You keep sampling
random Clauses?
>> As if they were
learned case you know,
as if it is uniform
learned on SAT.
>> And then you add
clauses. You can-
>> We start with
N variables and no clauses.
>> Okay.
>> We'll sample
a random uniform clause
on the N variables,
and check clause SAT over
to see if it's satisfiable.
>> Right.
>> If it's satisfiable
we do it again.
We keep adding
clauses like this.
>> So you keeping adding
clauses, okay that
wasn't clear here so.
>> Yeah. Sorry keep
sampling random clauses
and adding them until.
>> And keep adding
them until unSAT.
>> Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Sorry that wasn't clear.
>> The point is that,.
>> It's going a little fast.
>>So we know that before
the last clause is
introduced the problem
is still satisfiable.
So we know that
flipping any literal in
the last clause will preserve
the model that was
satisfying previously.
So we know we can recover
a satisfiable instance by
flipping a literal in
the final clause yeah.
Sorry if I'm going
too fast please
anyone stop me at anytime.
>> All right I get
it now. Okay thanks.
>> So, let's talk about
Network Architecture.
We could treat SAT problems as
character strings and use
standard sequence models.
We saw that, I wrote
a SAT problem above it's
characters so the AST standard
models can be applied.
But there are many invariances
that we want to enforce
that the logic of
satisfiability admits.
For example, SAT problems are
permutation invariant
in a few ways.
You can permute literals,
you can permute
clauses and you can
permute literals
within a clause.
And you don't want to
have a Sequence Model
have to learn all of
this from scratch.
We can just build
it into the model.
There are also
negation invariant.
Which means that you can
negate every occurrence
of any specific variable,
also without affecting
satisfiability.
So we're going to try to build
these invariances into
our Neural Network Model.
And the approach is given
a formula like this.
We're going to construct
an undirected graph with
a node for every literal so
there's a node for (X1 not X1),
(X2 not X2) and a node for
every clause C1 and C2.
There's going to be
one type of edge between
every literal and
every clause it appears in.
So there's an edge between
X1 and C1 and X2 and
C1 because C1 Contains
the literals X1 and X2.
And there's also a separate type
of Edge which I did note with
a dotted edge here between a
literal and its complement.
So X2 and not X2 are
connected by the dotted edge,
and X1 and not X1 are
connected by that edge.
Now the basic idea of the model
which we call NeuroSAT,
is we're going to maintain
a vector embedding
some inscrutable collection of
floating point numbers at
each node in the graph.
And we're going to
iterativly of we pass
messages along
the edges of the graph.
So, a literal is going
to pass messages to
the clauses it appears in
and its complement literal.
Clauses are going
to pass messages
back to the literals
that occur in them.
After teatime steps, we're
going to map literals
into scalar votes using
a learned network.
And then we're just
going to average
the votes to compute
a single logic
that's going to guess
whether the entire
problem is satisfiable or not.
Now I'm going to go
into the architecture
in great detail in
the next few slides.
But if you have
any high level questions
I'll take them now.
Yeah.
>>It's related to survey-
>>I'm going to discuss
every propagation a
little at the end.
Tree propagation does
not look like this.
There are several
architectural differences.
We'll cover Survey
Propagation with this.
In Survey Propagation
the messages
that the clauses
sends to the literal,
depends on which literal it is.
Like you marginalize
out the other literals,
which you can't
express in this way.
But it's structurally similar
in the sense that it's
a message-passing algorithm.
So, here's the NeuroSAT model
in more detail.
Where we have a bunch
of learned parameters.
So, two vectors, the
L init and C init
to initialize
the embeddings for each
of the literals and clauses.
Three multi-layer
preceptrons, L msg,
C msg and L vote.
I'll explain all
of these shortly,
and then two layer-norm LSTMs,
L update and C update.
Now, we're going to initialize,
one matrix that stores all
of the literal embeddings.
So, it's 2N by D,
so every row contains
the embedding for
one of the literals.
And we're going to
just initialize all
of the rows to L init,
the learned vector and
similarly for clauses.
Every row of C
is going to be the embedding
for one of the clauses.
And we're going to run
T iterations of message passing.
So, every iteration of
message passing
consists of two stages.
Stage one, literals are
going to pass messages
to the clauses.
So, here all of
the literals have
embeddings and
they're going to send
them to the clauses
that they occur in.
The clauses are going to sum
the incoming messages and
also get its previous state with
a started edge and use the rnn,
the C update layer-norm LSTM
to update its own embedding.
And here's the matrix notation.
It's hard to read but it
just says what I just said.
You've got the
literal embeddings.
You apply this learned
MLP to compute the messages,
one for each literal.
M is going to be
the binary adjacency matrix.
So, this is just summing
the messages and sending
them to the clauses and
then the clause also get
its previous hidden state
and it calls the update LSTM.
Now, the stage 2 is similar.
Clauses pass messages
to the literals.
The only difference here is that
the literals get messages
from the clauses,
it gets its old state
and it also gets
a different kind of
message from its complement
because of the extra edges
in the graph.
Intuitively, these dotted edges
encode the constraint
that they should probably
not be equal. Yes.
>> What is a message?
What are the messages?
>> So, every node has some,
at every time step
that every node has
some collection of
floating point numbers that
represent something
potentially inscrutable
about that node.
So, at every time step I
have some vector here which
represents something
hopefully meaningful
about the literal.
Now, that's represented in
this matrix L of t. L msg is
a learned Neural Network that
takes those embeddings and
computes some other vector
of floats that
represents a message.
But I have no a
priori knowledge of
what that actually
encodes semantically.
It has the freedom to choose
what those floats represent.
>> And what are these sizes
of the spectrum, again?
>> I don't think I said yet.
We eventually run it with
128 but is pretty arbitrary.
>> It's a good number.
>> If we had bigger
hardware we'd run it.
>> Got it. Okay, super.
>> As big as you can get.
>> It's related to
problem size potentially.
>> Potentially,
unclear actually.
>> Oh, okay, okay.
>> Because reduction sometimes
[inaudible] you don't always want.
I mean having a smaller vector
potentially versus
something distractive.
>> Conventional wisdom in
machine learning is used
as big a vector as
you can get away
with in terms of
hardware and performance.
We also found that it trains,
the bigger we made D
the faster it trained.
But it's not major. You
can train these with
16 even with eight first.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> And you're going
to describe how you
do the learning itself later?
>> Yeah, although
the short answer is background.
But I'll explain
the signal in a second.
So, here's the literals
and it's similar,
I won't go through
this in detail.
It's identical except for this,
except for getting
the compliment of
the literals as
a separate message
is the same as the clauses.
Now, after T iterations,
we're going to compute
a scalar "vote" for each
literal by applying
this learned multi-layer
perceptron on L vote,
that maps each literal
embedding into a single scalar.
We're going to then
average the votes to get
a logit which is
just a single scalar
for the entire network.
And then we're going to
predict satisfiability
using the logit by just
taking the sigmoid function,
which is going to return
something between zero and one.
Now, we train with
the cross entropy loss.
So, we're using
back propagation to minimize
the classification error on
a training dataset. Does that-
>> Where is the input
to your training?
>> SAT problems
represented as graphs and
a single bit of supervision
for each problem
indicating one if it's SAT,
zero if it's unSAT.
>> So you use
these pairs that you
were mentioning earlier.
Sets of these pairs,
large sets of these pairs.
>> Yes. Exactly. But typically,
we don't tell anything
about solutions.
We're just giving it single
bit supervision
for each problem.
Let's talk about
experiments now.
So, we're going to train
on SR uniform 10, 40.
The uniform part is
not actually essential.
It's just intuitively nice
to use a curriculum here because
it's going to be
harder to induce
structure on bigger problems.
But we train things
without the curriculum
and it works just as
well. And we're going to-
>> Are those variables
clauses, 10, 40?
>> No, sorry. Uniform meaning,
we're sampling the number
of variables from
a uniform distribution
between 10 and 40.
The number of
clauses is determined
by how many we can sample
before it get answered.
>> Answered, right.
>> And then we're going
to test on SR(40).
Just some perspective on SR(40).
There's 40 variables,
so there are
a trillion possible assignments.
About 200 clauses per problem.
Roughly 1000
literally occurrences,
so about five literals
per clause.
And all of the clauses
are uniformly random,
so every literal is
treated symmetrically.
Including X I and not X I are
both treated symmetrically.
And every single problem
in the distribution is a
single bit away from flipping
between SAT and unSAT.
And just a caveat,
because 40 is small,
it is still easy for
state of the results.
So many SAT can solve SR(40)
in almost [inaudible] number
of milliseconds.
And results NeuroSAT predicts
with 85 percent accuracy.
We're going to make that number
a lot better shortly,
but first let's
understand how it
even beat 50 percent. Yes.
>> So, intuitively
what you learn here,
is for any pair of formulas,
whether you have
the original unSAT
or if there's one flip
which become SAT.
That's what you are
learning here, correct?
>> Well, we don't tell
NeuroSAT that these two,
one is SAT one is unSAT.
They just get random problems
for distribution.
>> I see. So, when you
feed for the training,
you do not say that this one
was unSAT one and this was SAT?
>> Correct. We just feed them,
feed the individual problems.
>> But they're labeled.
>> They're labeled but
we don't tell NeuroSAT.
>> So, you do tell them.
>> We don't tell NeuroSAT that
they should look at this pair.
>> So, input is not a pair.
>> Every single
individual problem.
>> No, it's a SAT but he
says it's effectively what.
Okay, that's not a criticism,
I'm just trying to see
what the intuition,
if there's an intuition here.
What's the intuition that
you had in your head?
What's actually
been learned here...
>> We have actually a
very good explanation
of what's being learned,
which I'm going
to get to shortly.
>> Okay.
>> So, we were all really
surprised by this number
and we trained
a few baselines including
LSTMs and we could not break
50 percent on any of them.
We couldn't train
a model but even
when you fixed the number
of variables and fixed
the representation could even
distinguish on
small training sets,
the difference between
the SAT and unSAT problems.
So, the best way,
we actually bombarded this
with experiments and made
no progress until we just
visualized what it was doing
and then it became clear.
So, this is an example run of
NeuroSAT on a problem
from SR(20).
Here, this is the matrix
of scalar literal votes
at each time step.
So, this is a 20 by two matrix,
because there's 20 variables.
So, the Ith row is going to be
the scalar vote for X I
and then not X I in
the second column.
Here, white is zero,
red is positive, and
blue is negative.
Okay? So, red means SAT,
white means unsure,
blue means unSAT.
Now, as time goes on,
there's some red and blue
here from the
initialization which
is an artifact of
the initialization vectors.
But very quickly
all of the literals
start voting unSAT
with low confidence.
So, light blue means
roughly logit of negative one.
So, assigning, say
16 percent probability
just to it being SAT.
And you can see there's a lot
happening each time step.
A lot of the dots are
changing and moving around but
consistently almost all of
the literals are voting SAT
with low confidence.
And we see this on
every problem it runs on.
And this happens for a while,
unSAT with no confidence.
Quite a few things
are happening,
a few speckles of very,
very light red that
don't make any difference
because they get washed
out by the averaging.
But then, all of a sudden
there's a very distinct
phase transition.
All of the literals
start voting SAT with
extremely high confidence
and the network converges.
So, these light blues are
about negative one logit.
These reds are about plus 40.
So, this is 99.9999999 percent
sure that these problems
are satisfiable and
the network convergences.
We see this for every problem
that it runs on.
If it's unSAT, it looks
like this forever,
and if it's SAT it either
looks like this for
a long time or eventually
end, sometimes, usually,
eventually has
this phase transition
where it converges. Yes.
>> Just to make sure because
that's where we're at.
This is when you test
basically, not when
you learn, here. Right?
>> Yes, this is a problem
that was not trained up.
>> Okay, okay.
>> Yes. So, somehow
around here it becomes extremely
confident that this problem
is satisfiable.
Now, we weren't exactly
sure what it found
that convinced it.
But if you look carefully at
the literal votes
after convergence,
is a little hard to see
because the resolution is poor.
But you can maybe make out
a pretty distinct
checkerboard pattern.
Meaning that there
are only roughly two,
maybe three shades of red here.
And for each variable,
there's one literal that is
distinctly darker
than the other one.
So, you can see
a bit pattern here.
Do you guys all see it roughly?
>> [inaudible]
>> You wouldn't call it what?
>> Sorry, go ahead, go ahead.
>> So, we hypothesized that
maybe this is encoding
is satisfying assignment.
And that it had become so
confident because
it had found it.
So when we made
it a script to just
try to just read
this off and see if it's
a satisfying assignment,
and it turns out that it
usually is a
satisfying assignment.
Which suggests that the reason
why I became so
confident is actually
because it had detected
a satisfying assignment,
and knew that that indicated
that the problem
must be satisfiable.
Now, at first I thought maybe
the literals that are true in
the assignment are
voting SAT with
more confidence even though
I didn't know why
it would do that,
it turns out that
is not the case.
Sometimes, the literal
that is voting lower,
that is voting SAT
with less confidence,
is the one that's true
in the solution. Yeah.
>> [inaudible]
>> You try both possibilities.
So, you try the thing
that maps the one
that's lower to true everywhere,
and then you try
the one that's- Yeah.
But this has turned out to be
an unreliable way to
decode the solutions.
It turns out that
this pair pattern is
just an artifact of the fact
that the higher dimensional
literal embeddings cluster
according to the assignment.
So at convergence, in
the 128 dimensional space,
the literals that are true
are going to be in one cluster,
the literals that are
false are going to
be in another cluster.
And this pair pattern is just
an artifact of the projection
preserving that clustering
most of the time.
>> Excuse me. If
you have this set,
you have two [inaudible]
and run it through this.
And one cluster could be the
true and the other
could be the false.
>> Am not.
>> And suppose that you
have two disjoint sets of
literals that appear
disjoint sets of clauses,
then would your learning
necessarily correlate when is
light verses dark in
one cluster or the other?
>> That's a good question.
In that case, it is
conceivable that you would
end up with four clusters.
The true ones for problem one,
the false ones for problem one.
My guess is that we didn't test
that SR40s are just
fully connected.
My guess is that
the two clusters
for the two sets of true
literals are going to
be closer together,
and then for two cluster,
you'll still get
the right solution.
But I don't have
a proof of that.
But the clustering
analysis suggests
a much more reliable way
to decode solutions.
Which is just directly cluster
the higher dimensional
embeddings.
So here we can watch
the two dimensional
PCA projections of
the high dimensional
and embeddings
on a run from SR40.
Now, I've colored the literal,
these are the
literal embeddings.
And I've colored
them according to
the solution that
eventually finds.
So you can see exactly what
it's doing over time.
These are just the
last nine times steps
leading up to convergence.
And you see it doesn't cluster
at all, it's all mixed up.
It's all mixed up. It's sort
of starting to separate.
Here it's starting to separate,
but one literal is
still incorrect.
And then it pulls away and then
that convergence falls
into two distinct clusters.
And now this method of
decoding is very reliable.
And 96 percent of
the problems in
the test distribution
for which I guess is set,
this simple trick
of two clustering
will recover the
satisfying assignment.
So let's talk about
solving. Oh yeah.
>> Because it doesn't really use
any supervision for
finding that out.
>> Right.
>> Do you have to
any sort of [inaudible]
>> Yeah. So, as I said before
the training distribution.
The satisfiable problems and
the unsatisfiable problems
are statistically identical.
There is no way
for it to predict
that bit based on
superficial properties.
It learned that
the best way to predict
that bit is to search for
satisfying assignments.
And not to get SAT until it
found one at which point,
guess that with
extreme confidence and
suffer no objective
function cost.
Yeah. I think it's
an artifact of
the distribution not permitting
any other way of
explaining the data.
We're going to talk
about training it on
slightly different distributions
later in the talk,
and you'll see how
the training data
affects the procedure
that it learns.
So let's talk about
solving the rest.
Sometimes, there are
satisfiable problems
for which it does not guess SAT.
It will continue to
guess on SAT with
low confidence.
Here's an example.
Just keeps wandering around,
but because NeuroSAT is
inherently iterative,
we can just run it for
more iterations and
see what happens.
So we run this, run this,
run this for a long time.
Fast forward to around 137.
We only trained
and tested so far
on 26 rounds of message passing.
So this is five or
six times more rounds
than it ever performed
during training.
And all the literals are still
voting on SAT with
low confidence.
Few speckles of red and
then round 150, bam!
Face transition, extremely
confident in SAT,
the literal embeddings converge.
And once again this bit pattern
will usually encode
a satisfying assignment.
And the clustering technique is
even more reliable as always.
Now, here's a graph
showing the percentage
of problems from
SR(40)SR that it solved as
a function of the number of
rounds of message passing.
So it solves about 70 percent
at 26 rounds because that
is what we trained it on.
But as we run it for longer,
it continues to
solve more and more.
By about a thousand rounds
of message passing,
it's solving
just about 100 percent
of the problems in
the test distribution SR(40)SR.
And this is solving end to end.
This is not just
prediction accuracy.
We are decoding solutions for
almost 100 percent of
the problems in
the test distribution.
And curves like this are,
I think it's fair to say fairly
unprecedented in
machine learning.
Usually, algorithms
are not iterative.
And even when they
are, they don't
just continue to do better
when you run longer.
>> So, what answer can you
give the SAT over there?
>> We're going to
talk about this later.
Right now, no. Right now
it wanders around forever.
When trained on SR(40)SR,
it will never become
confident in on SAT,
but we're going to
talk about this later.
There are a few
cool experiments.
Now, it would be
implausible to solve
much bigger or
harder problems with
only 26 rounds of
message passing.
You can imagine that
it's just not possible to
reliably solve big hard problems
with so few rounds.
But because we can
run for more rounds,
and it continues to
search effectively,
it's conceivable
what we can actually
solve problems that are harder.
So, let's talk about
scaling to bigger problems.
Here, this purple line
is the same line I just showed
you on the previous graph.
And we are plotting
the same lines for
SR of N for larger
N. So SR(80)SR,
SR 120, SR 160, and SR 200.
And we see similar curves
where for SR(80)SR,
instead of 70 percent,
it's only able to solve
maybe 40 percent when you
only run it for 26 iterations.
But as you run it
for up to a thousand,
it's solving about 90 percent
of the problems.
And even SR 200,
which is substantially
harder problem,
and many SAT is now starting
to noticeably slow down on.
It's solving... It solves under
five percent of the number
of rounds it was trained on.
But it gets up
to almost 30 percent
when you run it for
a thousand rounds.
Now again, although from
a machine learning perspective,
the fact that these curves
go up at all when you
extrapolate the number of rounds
is interesting and impressive.
But it also suggests that
the algorithm as is
is highly incomplete.
It's possible that this curve
spikes up, we didn't
run it for longer.
But it looks like
it's asymptotic. Yeah.
>> What was your training size,
how many SAT problems,
how many examples do you fit
your training algorithms?
>> It's a stream.
So, I don't actually have
the exact number. Probably.
>> Roughly?
>> A few million.
>> A few million?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> But none of the problems
are bigger than SR(40)SR.
We are training on
SR 10 to SR(40)SR.
So our hypothesis for
why it flattens out
here is that during training,
it's essentially performing
some kind of local search,
and it never has to
restart during training.
SR(40)SR is easy enough.
That is heuristics
are essentially
complete without needing to
revert when it gets stuck.
So when we watch it run,
it very quickly
makes every step.
The first few steps,
it will flip many,
many literals at
a time and very quickly
satisfy over 99 percent
of the clauses.
And then, it will start taking
much more cautious steps
flipping only a few literals.
And we see for
these longer runs and
the big problems that it
just stops being aggressive.
Now, we think
an architectural change
that would make it much more
reliable when run on
harder problems for
many iterations is giving it
access to a source
of randomness.
So it has some way to
learn when it's stuck
and when it should inject
noise into its embedding.
So, we haven't tried
this yet. Yeah.
>> It's true what
you see around this
is all what you mean
by the iterations?
So you have this
recurrence relation
between CI and CI plus one,
H and these are
the transformations
that you buy, and the X-axis?
>> Yes. Every iteration
here involves
the literals passing messages to
the clauses and the clauses
passing messages
back to the literals.
>> How fast is that dimensions
in the iteration cost?
>> Sorry.
>> Go ahead.
>> So, let me go back
and show you the updates.
So, it's applying
a single neural network here,
which is as fast as
applying, that is.
In this case, it's
a three-layer neural network.
It's just basically a couple of
matrix modes as far as
matrix modes for the graph,
for the message passing, and
then the C update is
another matrix mode.
So, it depends on
the dimension and
the number of literals,
but it's not expensive. Yes.
>> But compared
to sets, methods,
space, and message
passing of which.
I guess it would be
permutation, is one example,
and the difference then is
the matrix modification,
and where the
modifications come from?
>> So, Survey Propagation
is not learned at all.
It's derived mathematically.
The structure of
the messages is different.
So as I said before,
a clause will pass
different messages to
the literals that occur in it.
Here, that clause that pass
the same messages
to every literal,
so there are
a couple architectural
differences like that.
Numerically, the very
difference of Survey Prop
often fails for
numerical reasons
that you're dividing by zero.
And here, there's
no division. So it's-.
>> But, I thought that
philosophical difference would be
these matrix multiplications
that you get from your end.
>> I don't know if
that's a philosophical
difference,
but that's a big difference.
That there's a lot more
floating point computation being
done per iteration here
than in Survey Propagation.
Survey Propagation, it's
a few multiplications
and divisions
on a single float for
each literal and clause. Yes.
>> I'm just trying
to suit the comment
that you made earlier
about the training.
So, for each of these five here,
we have different training
sets that you used?
>> No, this is all- sorry.
Everything we're talking
about today until
the very end is just trained
on SR uniform 10 and 40.
>> Okay.
>> This is all extrapolation
to bigger problems.
It has not been retrained.
>> So, SR 10?
What is SR 10 and 40?
What is that?
>> Sorry, SR uniform 10, 40,
curriculum, training on SR,
somewhere between 10 and 40.
The end is randomly
sampled between 10 and 40.
>> So, for 80 for instance,
so the training set.
Basically, what's going on?
The algorithms is picking
patterns that are learned from
smaller instances
between 10 and 40,
like if you get it to 200,
you tried to detect
these patterns somehow, correct?
>> I don't think that's
the best way to think of it.
It's not the way I think
about it. I think that
there are very few patterns
that's exploiting.
And rather than
looking for patterns,
it is synthesized
a local search algorithm,
which is what makes
it generalized where
the patterns would-
>> What incidents
do you have for
your interpretation?
So for instance-
>> Yes. So, I think if we go
back to the video in action.
I think this is actually-.
>> This is a visualization
of the duration
of the algorithm.
It doesn't show to study
the pattern learned,
and it is being identified
in a test sample.
I mean how do you see it?
>> I'm not sure I
understand the distinction.
I think this is
rock solid evidence
that it learns that it needs
to find somehow a search
for satisfying assignments,
and that is the best way to
explain the supervision bit.
>> But how does it find this?
>> That, I can only speculate.
>> It's by pattern recognition,
that's why I'm asking
where you've learned this.
>> I have one relevant
experiment here.
Trying to tell whether it
was doing a local search or
global search. It's not clear.
So, we can decode
the solution by
doing this two clustering
technique at the end.
It's not clear
that if we cluster,
it's meaningful
before convergence.
But, we hypothesized
that maybe it
is an inconsistent assignment
before convergence,
and we tested what properties
that assignment had.
So when we do this,
we see that the number of
clauses satisfied increased
monotonically very quickly
and rarely go down,
and we see that the number
of literals that are flipped at
each time step starts out high,
and as the number of
clauses satisfied goes up,
the number of literals
flipped, goes down.
So qualitatively, it looks
a lot like local search,
some kind of an nearly.
But, it's not clear
what stronger evidence
would constitute
because ultimately,
the algorithm is inscrutable.
I can't read
the matrix instance to
understand specifically
what it's doing.
>> And we know somehow that
it's also getting stuck from
the graphs and the margins.
>> Yes.
>> Because it appears
to be plateauing.
>> Yes.
>> So, it's not learning
enough from backtracking,
enough to go search some
other space because it seems
so limited in what
it's scope, somehow.
>> Yes.
>> Because of the size.
>> I think the lack of
needing to do any kind of
restart during training.
it's just not prepared
for such hard problems.
Are you satisfied? Do you have
another hypothesis
for what it's doing?
>> Well, I think the experiment
that might be interesting.
If you were using
just a sequence to
sequence based on strings,
string encoding
of volume sensors,
how would- can you approximate
your result? Is there-
>> We implemented
a baseline and could not be
50 percent on the
classification testing.
>> I see.
>> There's two reasons
why I think
those approaches can't
get off the ground.
One is that, there's
no obvious way to deliberate.
I mean to deliberate,
to run for a long time.
A crucial part of
neuroscience is that,
it's iterative, that
it can think longer.
A single pass over a sequence
is very unlikely to be able
to solve than big,
hard problems.
But also, it's just has to
spend all of its time learning
the invariances
that we build in.
It's another thing.
There's so many different
common permutation invariances,
exponential number of that.
>> But, if you were to
normalize the inputs
for instance by,
you sort for each
clause literals by name,
and you could get part of
that, and still
had this straight.
So that would perhaps
help test the pattern
theory so to speak,
the simple fact
of recognition so
far would prove powerful for
its context. I don't know.
>> Maybe. I would
be very surprised if
somebody could be
50 percent with
something that didn't have
this iterative formulation,
but I would be
thrilled to be proved
wrong about that. Yes.
>> So, with regards to this
picking up the patterns,
you mentioned that you used
this SR distribution because you
don't want to pick up
some bad node terms.
>> Yes. We designed it to
try to prevent it from,
to be able to
exploit the patterns.
>> So, did you actually do
the other experiment
of completely
running a
randomly-generated data,
so that you see what
are the accuracies?
>> Unfortunately, no.
We've trained on
regular random set
at the empirical threshold,
and it does perform well also.
But that's almost
as patternless as
our distribution because all
of the literals are of
the same statistics.
Even though there's not
a single bit separated,
most of the problems is at the
empirical threshold
are going to be-.
>> Which data set this is?
Which data set this is?
>> So, the data set
we generate SR event.
>> Right.
>> It is very similar to
the standard uniform
random set of problems.
>> Okay.
>> The only difference is that,
we adjust the number of
clauses specifically for
each problem to find
the exact threshold where
it flips from set to onset.
But what you can
do is, you can just
sample for a given end.
That threshold is usually at
the same number of clauses,
roughly 4.27 clauses
per variable ratio.
So, if you just sample
that number of clauses
for a fixed end,
you're going to be a few flips
away from flipping
my construction.
We trained on that, and it
also has a similar quality.
>> What I'm trying to say that,
if your hypothesis is true,
then the other way
training on that,
the other data set should
do significantly better
because you can pick up
the patterns specific
to the data set?
>> Yes. So, I don't
know if the random set
has such patterns
close to the threshold.
But, I think one of the promises
of this technique is,
if there is a distribution
of set problems that
has special structure that
you care about in practice,
that this could
learn a less generic,
more constant procedure to
exploit the patterns
in that data set.
Yes. But, you have to be
careful with the data set.
If you can predict
satisfiability on
the data set based on
superficial patterns.
If you have some degenerate
data set where
your satisfiable problems
come from planning and
your unsatisfiable problems
come from scheduling,
it could potentially predict
with perfect accuracy based on
patterns without learning that
it needs to search for
satisfying assignments.
So, it wouldn't be useful.
Ideally, the usefulness
of the patterns
is limited enough,
that it has to learn to search,
but it uses the patterns
to help search better.
There's a lot of art in
the data set design I think,
and we're going to see
networks that are trained on
a different data set shortly
to really stress this point.
Let me fast forward.
Okay. Let's talk about
generalizing to other domains.
So, all of the test problems so
far have been uniform random,
which may have
its own statistical
idiosyncrasies or may just,
it's just inherently
uninteresting to some extent.
There are an
incredible diversity
of possible SAT problems.
Almost hard to conceive how
the simple formalism can
express such a great variety
of different kinds of problems.
Any problem in NP can
be reduced to SAT,
and the structural and
statistical properties
can really vary widely.
So, an actual question is,
does NeuroSAT trained
on the random problems
generalize to other
domains or is it just
exploiting properties
of random SAT?
Now to test this, we generated
a suite of diverse SAT problems.
So first, we generated
random graphs from a bunch of
different random
graph distributions,
Spare Bósi, Erdos-Renyi,
Forest Fire, and a few others.
Small graphs all of
them look roughly
like this about 10
Nodes, 17 Edges.
For each graph, we generated
K-coloring problems,
K- dominating set problems,
K- clique problems
and K-cover problems.
All four range of K. Where
we choose K so that
of at the hard end,
under 50% are satisfiable and at
the easy end all of
them are satisfiable.
And if you look at this graph,
yeah if I remember correctly
this is a four clique,
and I don't think
there's a five clique.
You can look at least
with pen and paper and
some thought you can
solve all of these problems but
they're not
perceptually obvious.
Require reasoning and some kind
of search even for humans.
But again trivial for us,
that's all we're just
because of the size.
And just to really
stress the diversity,
I want to show you
a few visualizations.
So this is a visualization
of a problem from SR40.
Here every red node
is a literal;
the red edges are between a
literal and its complement.
And there's a blue edge between
any pair of literals that
appear in the same clause.
So this is a lousy
representation
because we're marginalizing
of the clauses.
You can see that there's
just no structure
it's just a big tangled mess.
Here is a, this beast
is a problem from SR200.
You can see again
there's no structure.
It's just an unbelievable
tangled mess.
Now just a reminder,
NeuroSAT gets graphs like
this that takes time,
where flipping a single
edge changes whether
it's SAT or UNSAT.
And it's able to
look at this and
compute at least
30% of the cases,
whether it's SAT
or UNSAT correctly.
And actually, return
the satisfying
assignment that
explains that bit.
Now in contrast here's
a graph coloring problem,
which has this crystalline
structure also very few edges.
Here's a quick detection problem
where you've got
this special pattern for
each of the five cliques.
There's a dominating
SAT problem also has
a very distinct structure
that is distinctly non-random,
and vertex cover problem
also has its own
little distinct flair.
Just to stress how
different these domains are.
Now let's look at the results.
So in total over
this suite of problems,
there were almost 5,000
satisfiable problems.
Average number of
clauses is a 532.
So about two and a half times
bigger than the biggest problems
seen during training.
And NeuroSAT solves 85% of
the satisfiable
problems end to end.
So again it's just trained on
small random problems
for 26 iterations,
and now it's solving, and
it's finding solutions to
85% of problems that are
bigger across a suite
of different domains.
And in contrast,
the percent solved by
Survey Propagation end
to end is zero percent.
So Survey Propagation just
simply doesn't work on these.
It usually doesn't converge,
or it keeps oscillating
between one,
zero and then zero, one.
It's not completely a fair
comparison because Survey Prop
is not designed to solve
problems end to end,
it's usually used in decimation,
where it just provides
a heuristic for which
variables to SAT.
But I keep these numbers here to
stress that as far as I know,
we don't know of
a message passing
algorithm with qualitatively
similar behavior to NeuroSAT.
So it hasn't just
relearned an algorithm
that we know about,
it's doing something new that we
don't know how to explain. Yeah.
>> But for the random problems,
solving problems.
>> Yeah random problems.
I haven't run it
on SRM but on run
CMF so every Prop will
solve a decent fraction.
>> Okay.
>>It doesn't work.
So ironically Survey Propagation
is derived
mathematically without
reference to a random SAT.
And doesn't generalize to
non-random SAT problems as well.
They are actually
trained on random SAT.
But there's already
something more
general that lets it transfer.
Okay now, let's
talk about. Yeah.
>> How do your results compare
to the classic
the overall results
of phase transition for
random SAT instances.
>> So our SR of n is designed to
the phase transition is
only really hold asymptotically
as the number of variables
goes to infinity.
So for small n and
like n equals 40.
If you find the
empirical threshold which
is something like 4.62,
50% will be satisfiable,
and 50% will be unsatisfiable.
You are not actually
going to be one little
away from flipping in general.
As n goes to infinity,
adding a single clause with
high probability will flip
you from SAT to UNSAT.
But for smaller n,
the actual threshold
has higher variance.
So SR of n is basically
just a way of
correcting for that.
So that every problem is
exactly at its own
personal threshold.
>> So you're saying that
for small problem instances,
the threshold like clause
density SAT that one would use
to guess this high accuracy
doesn't work well,
or it's too noisy.
>> Yes. This variance
about where
that threshold is going
to be for small n.
>> But on the other hand,
is there possible
explanations of how
using randomized
style algorithm,
random algorithm that
would explain that
these somehow perhaps these
randomly generated
problems that you
consider are could easy to solve
from this probabilistic
point of view.
Like equivalent
of explaining how
the old phase
transition phenomenon
appears basically.
Something equivalent.
>> I have empirical
evidence against that.
Which is that as
you would expect,
since it's essentially
at the threshold,
there are many SAT
will really start to
grind and then gets bigger.
Because our Ks are bigger
than three on average,
about five on average.
Many SAT will start
to grind more than it
would even for a random Pre SAT
as n gets bigger.
>>So what about SAT comes
from problems people
use to practice,
do you rub it? Is
that competition?
>> We didn't. I think
the current version trained
only the way we've trained it,
it's unlikely to be
able to deal with
such big problems without
additional training.
>> Just because of
that graph. Okay.
>> Yeah. I've already
told you about all of
the problems we've run about.
>> Yes.
>> I think the breathe is
strong enough to suggest
that it's generalizing to
different kinds of SAT problems.
I don't think it's close to
being useful on big problem.
>> The quick thing is
perhaps your reference to
mean SAT I don't know
exactly what he does.
But it's not a proof that
such an algorithm thing
doesn't exist that
[inaudible] Its just
I don't know how it is
related to actually what I
have just asked but anyway,
so I say is there
randomize algorithm that could
basically explain
the why these clause of
random programming instances
that you consider is easy
or hard to solve or to guess
whether it's SAT or not.
Then you answer all
these [inaudible]
>> I'm not so familiar with
the theory on the difficulty
of randoms setting and stuff.
My understanding and
maybe Rio can correct
me is that at least
as n goes to infinity,
at the threshold,
the problems are thought to
be exponentially difficult.
Now n is small here,
so we don't have
any specific proof for n,
we're not actually
sampling at threshold,
we're sampling at
this problems specific
threshold, but it's believed,
I believe that there are
if not theoretical results,
theoretical conjunctions.
>> So it had to be
a hard problem in general.
I have no idea in terms of
time check what you just said.
>> No.
>> But I don't want to.
>> When the thread, if
you're sampling the number of
clauses below the threshold
it is known to be easy.
So Survey Propagation
with decimation can solve.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Like 99 percent of
the problems with n I think
100,000 if the clause to
variable ratio was
just a little bit under
the threshold. We
know those are easy.
>> I see. Okay, thank you.
>> But we are trying
to make these as
hard as possible by sampling at
the threshold for smaller
n. But I don't have
any proof these are hard,
and I'm not relying
on it for any of
the takeaways from dual set.
>> What is this threshold again?
>> Yes. So, if you
have n variables,
and you're sampling clauses
uniformly at random,
let's say with all clauses
of three literals in them.
If you only sample
a couple of clauses with
high probability it's probably
going to be satisfiable.
If you sample a million clauses
with high probability it's
going to be unsatisfiable.
The point is that for
every fixed number of variables,
there are some number
of clauses where
there's a 50 percent chance
it will be satisfiable,
and a 50 percent chance
it will be unsatisfiable.
And those are the hard regimes.
So, if there are
a million clauses it's
probably going to be
unSAT for a simple reason.
You probably sampled
just some small unSAT core.
And if there's no clauses
it's satisfiable
for a simple reason,
anything you try is
going to be work,
and it's difficult
right at the threshold.
But again this is not
particularly relevant to
NeuroSAT or the claims or
takeaways from this project.
Okay. Let's talk about
detecting unsatisfiability,
this is what you
asked about before.
So NeuroSAT at least
trained on SR uniform (10,
40) is never confident in unSAT.
It searches indefinitely.
It searches poorly indefinitely,
meaning it stopped taking
big moves and it gets stuck
but it searches indefinitely.
And it always guesses
low confidence unSAT
until it finds a solution.
Now, detecting SAT and unSAT
are very different problems.
Now, proofs of SAT are
just variable assignments.
In particular, they
fit in NeuroSAT memory.
NeuroSAT has a memory
as a couple of floats
for each literal.
And it just needs to
represent a bit mask on
those embeddings to be
able to encode
the satisfying assignment.
Whereas proofs of unSAT vary.
So there are some
trivial proofs of unSAT.
So, any formula no
matter how big if it has
the clause X1 and the cause
not X1 is unsatisfiable.
You don't have to
look at the rest of
the problem to know
it's unsatisfiable.
But others require
exponential time or
space to establish
unsatisfiability.
In some proof calculus
where the objects are
potentially unbounded
in particular
will not fit in
NeuroSAT's memory.
So even if it was able to
use some kind of stack,
data structure we wouldn't
be able to trivially
decode proofs because they
won't even fit in the final
embeddings for NeuroSAT.
But, we hypothesize it if
the unsatisfiable problems in
the trainings set
have short proofs,
NeuroSAT will
learn to find them.
And to test this we generated
the data set where like SR of N,
the data comes in pairs,
one SAT and one unSAT,
and they differ by negating a
single literal and
a single clause,
but this time by construction,
the unSAT problems
have small unSAT cores.
And we do this in a simple way,
we define this new
distribution SRC(n,
u) where u is an unSAT core.
And we start with
the small unSAT core u,
over a small number of
variables k less than
n. We're going to flip one
literal to make it SAT.
We pick the unSAT core
so that this works.
We add clauses as long as
it remains satisfiable.
So until it becomes unSAT.
We flip the same literal
back in the unSAT core,
to reintroduce the unsat core.
So we have a satisfiable
problem here,
and then we reintroduce
the unsat core by flipping a
single literal to construct
the unsatisfiable problem.
And we return the pair before
and after that final flip.
And we train NeuroSAT
on SRC( 40, u),
where u is sampled from
a small fixed SAT of core.
I think we used four cores.
Pigeon hole 2,1 pigeon hole 3,
2, the rivest unsat
core and one other.
>> The core...
>> We are going to
talk about this.
So, NeuroSAT is only
trained as a classifier,
and we're going to see if
we can decode the cores.
>> Oh yes. So you
don't [inaudible]
>> NeuroSAT, the interface
doesn't a priori regime.
>> Sorry, I forgot
that you also for
the SAT we could use this cycle.
>> Yes. And the results
we get 100 percent accuracy on
the test that in
five minutes training.
It's a much easier problem than
the first distribution
which you would expect.
Now let's see how
it actually works.
So here's a run.
We call this NeuroUNSAT by
the way when we train it
on this just to
keep them separate.
This is the same kind of
visualization we saw before.
And the first six rows
correspond to the six variables
that are part of the unsat core.
So this is P.P. three
pigeonhole principle three, two.
And you see that these
are voting unsat.
It clearly recognizes that
those six variables
are worth looking at.
It does some kind
of computation,
and eventually concludes
that it's not an unsat core.
And then all the literal
start voting SAT.
In contrast, here's
the same problem
but with the unsat core
reintroduced.
It starts out
almost identically,
doing some computation on
the six variables
involved in the core.
And eventually concludes that
actually is an unsat core.
And all of the variables in
the core vote unsat with
extremely high confidence.
This is black. This is
like negative 100 logit.
So this is extremely
high confidence and
completely outweighs
these plus one, plus twos.
So this suggests that it
has learned to at least
memorize the unsat cores
that we planted in
the data set. Yeah.
>> So the variables are
the literals set up
to clause variables.
>> Yes. These are
the literal votes.
>> So to select
the unsat core you have
to figure out what are
the clauses within...
>> Yes. But I'm going to
talk about this right now.
So, first let's talk about just
recovering the literals
that are in the unsat core.
As you can guess,
you can just look at
which ones are voting
unsat, the most confidence.
And that is usually
going to consist of
exactly the literals
in the unsat core.
But as before,
a more reliable approach is
to cluster the literal
embeddings of the final timestep.
And when we do that, we see
that there is a problem in SR
100 with same pigeonhole
principle core implanted.
And the 188 literals that
are not in the core are in
their own cluster and
the 12 literals that are
part of the core are
in their own cluster.
And this decoding trick
works 98 percent of the time
on the test set SRC(40, u).
But as you raise,
this is not
exactly what you want.
You actually want
the unsat core.
So, you can use
this as long as the number
of literals are small,
you can still construct
a proof efficiently
by just knowing that you
should branch on these first.
The reason why we
don't get unsat
cores is that we're using,
the literal embeddings are
forced to be more semantic
because we're using them to
vote about satisfiability.
If the architecture would...
If our aim was to
get unsat cores,
we would predict based on
the clauses instead
of the literals.
And then the clauses
would be more
semantic and would cluster.
But we don't test this
partly because during
training we batch together
problems that have
the same number of
variables and different
numbers of clauses.
So it's just, the way we set
things up it was easier to
batch where we only
predict from the literals since
the number of
clause has changed.
But in principle, with
a more clever system
you can predict based
on the clauses or both,
and then potentially get
the unsat core directly.
But it clearly has
the right semantic information.
It clearly knows
about the unsat core.
Let me summarize
the results so far.
We train NeuroSAT as a
classifier on random problems for
a few dozen iterations per
problem and it works
well as a classifier.
It learns to solve
the problems on its
own in order to explain
the supervision bit,
and we can almost always
decode a solution
when it guesses SAT.
It extrapolates well, so we
can run for more iterations.
It can solve
much bigger problems,
not with perfect reliability
but quite often,
and it can solve problems
from a wide range of domains.
Lastly, it learns
different algorithms
depending on the training data.
So in SR40,
where we don't think there
are small UNSAT cores,
it learns to search for
satisfying assignments
and in src40 where we
apply the UNSAT cores,
it learns to detect
them instead of
searching for
satisfying assignments.
Now, I want to share
what I think are
the main lessons and
takeaways from NeuroSAT.
First to answer the question
I posed in the beginning.
Yes a Neural network
can learn to
perform precise
logical reasoning.
It might not be
perfect, it might
have some extrapolation errors,
but for the most part
it's clearly doing,
it clearly knows when it has
found a satisfying assignment.
And this is a bit
sensitive property.
It's sensitive to
individual bit flips in
the input and so forth.
Two, I think this is
the most interesting part,
stochastic gradients descent
or back propagation alone,
can find such programs without
any discreet search even
with very weak supervision.
So, it's almost amazing but
the search algorithm emerges
smoothly and gradually
from back propagation.
There's no moment where
it learns to search.
The accuracy just gradually
goes up and up during training.
And in by the end,
it has synthesized
a search procedure
but there's no moment
when it does that,
there's no discrete search,
it's a smooth process.
It's such an alien
computational model
that it's hard to even imagine
but this is what we found.
Third, message passing
architectures are,
I think, surprisingly
powerful and flexible.
So the same
architecture was generic
enough to learn
two very different algorithms
depending on the training data.
One is a search
procedure and one
is this subgraph detector.
And in fact, we have
other experiments where we train
with literal level
supervision and it seems
to learn an entirely
different algorithm that's
more like a pattern
recognition system
with no phase change,
no evidence of detecting
satisfying assignments.
So I think it's
a really generic architecture
that can encode many different
kinds of computation.
And fourth, random training
data can be useful.
So conventional wisdom is that,
random training data prevents
learning patterns in that
if you train on random data,
it's extremely unlikely to
generalize to problems
that you care about.
But we actually make
use of this property.
We use random training
data to prevent
learning patterns exactly to
force it to learn an algorithm.
We force it to be
more systematic.
We don't think that there are
enough patterns to exploit in
SR40 to be able to predict
that bit without
being more systematic,
and we use this
to our advantage.
And finally, I want to just talk
about SAT solving in
practice very briefly.
So modern SAT solvers as most
of you know are extremely
well engineered.
They can solve
real-world problems
with literally millions
of variables.
They're really among
the technological
marvels of our time.
In contrast, NeuroSAT at least
as is trained in the regime
that we trained it,
is vastly less reliable and
efficient and scalable
than state-of-the-art.
I want to make that clear.
However, we still have
no idea what NeuroSAT is
and is not capable of.
So, we really only trained
on toy scale so far.
We train on
small random problems,
for a few dozen iterations,
for a few hours,
on a single GPU.
And conventional wisdom
in machine learning is
that scaling alone can
be extremely powerful,
and it's a mistake to
assume you know an upper bound
on how well your system is
going to do until you really
scale it up on more data
and bigger hardware.
And also, there's a lot of
potential room for improvement
in the architecture itself.
We're talking about giving
it a source of randomness as
one way that might
lead synthesize
a much richer search procedure.
And lastly, the
hardware projections are
extremely favorable for
this kind of approach.
So, hardware used by
traditional SAT solvers
as you all know,
has stagnated and
the free lunches are over.
In contrast, the Neural
network hardware renaissance
is just beginning and
one day a descendant
of NeuroSAT might
actually be able to
beat state-of-the-art,
although we have no evidence
of this right now and I
don't think it's anywhere.
I don't think it's
right around the corner,
but 10 years out if the hardware
improves by a 1000X,
I think it's possible.
And that's all I
have, thank you.
>> So, in a very abnormal knots,
people have been adding
all sorts of black memories,
and I mean the obvious thing
is the stack,.
>> Yeah.
>> Right? And so do you have
>> That's a great question.
>> Converting, adding
new memories to this?
>> So before we came up with
the unSAT core experiment,
we were trying to get it to do
exhaustive search and we gave it
access to a Neural stack,
and it didn't use, on SR40.
I think we could
have come up with
training data regimes where
it was an incentive to use it,
but SR40, it's able to
explain it by
searching in a number
of times steps we allow but
I think it's a good idea.
Intuitively it's what
it need to be, yeah.
>> Right, and in general I mean,
I think when you're
learning programs.
I mean, there's
a whole thought that will,
to make the Neural net
more comprehensible,
let's give it some basic
data structures
we do understand,
and use this but
I don't know how
successful that
also control flow
and program synthesis
sort of says,
well let's try to use
machine learning and
get the readable program
out and well,
that's all they're topic.
>> I think the algorithm
it learns could not be
converted to a simple
reasonable program.
>> Right. Most Neural
net like we don't have
a chance of extracting
these things right now though.
There's been some work on
getting decision trees,
I don't know that, I
wouldn't follow that.
>> I think this is,
this project is
some evidence that we
might still be
underestimating how
powerful the algorithm that it
learn the
incomprehensible ones that
it learns might mean even
without being able to extract.
>> So there's also something
interesting which is
like you are doing
fix point iteration,
whereas a lot of the uses of
the training models
are one shop, right?
And so, there's also,
you're inherently
doing a fix point with
no conversion guarantee but
well that is also
true now, isn't it?
Because in a lot of applications
we just simply don't
have the time right?
We need to look at the picture
and very quickly classify.
There's a pedestrian
industry right?
But here, you're working
in a regime where,
well, that's all we can take
time we can also just figure.
I mean you have a model
that's iterable.
>> Yes. Partly that
the problems are
hard enough to merit
the extra computation.
>> Right, exactly.
>> There have been a lot of
projects in the
last few years that
use a similar message
passing architecture.
>> Yes.
>> But they usually only run
for three or four rounds.
They're doing
something juristic,
not procedural like they're
predicting links selling on
social network graphs
or something like that,
where it's not clear that
the extra computation helps,
and they've shown extrapolation
to more rounds improving
performance at all.
I think part of this is.
Going back to the unSAT
core visualization.
In Neuro UNSAT,
it does not make use
of more rounds at all.
If you run it for
one more round,
it loses this information.
It doesn't even converge.
It's learned this very
precise algorithms end
up here at the right time.
>> Yes.
>> And it has no reason to
preserve that information.
So it's really an artifact of
the training regime that it was
incentivized to learn something
that would extrapolate
to more rounds.
And part of the reason is that,
these UNSAT cores is
the same UNSAT core each time.
So it's only four different
subgraph detectors it needs.
It can time how long it takes.
Whereas, for searching for
sense when it's timing,
it's going to find
a different iteration numbers.
So it needs to learn to
preserve that information.
So it learns to
converge around those.
Even though it's not
trained for more iterations,
it least learns convergence.
Because sometimes it's
going to find it on
iteration five,
sometimes iteration 15,
and it's penalized
very heavily for
losing the solution
that it counts.
>> Okay, cool. So, if you threw
randomness into this
and parallelize,
you might bump up these curves.
A bit that you showed for
the larger instances
that's purely to be used.
>> I think for us, I start to
wonder we can get 100% accuracy.
>> Really?
It's randomization,
just adding randomly.
>> And just training
on sr100, SR200.
>> Oh sure, sure, you're
doing the training there.
>> Yeah.
>> But it would be
nice to just train on
smaller instances
and then probably
just have some
technique to boost.
>> Yeah. So I don't know how,
I think empirically, 40 is
not hard enough to make,
it needs to learn something
that can do restart.
Maybe at 100 it can
learn something really
general that would extrapolate
to much bigger problems.
I don't think you
need to train on
exactly the size you
are going to test on.
But you need to train
on something that
is qualitatively in some
similar ballpark of difficulty.
Or at least it's hard
enough to require
you to learn the tricks you need
to solve the bigger problem.
One of the things I really
want to stress is just how
sensitive what it learns
is to the training data.
It will learn essentially
the simplest thing
that lets it predict well
on the training data,
and if that simple thing is
not what you need to
solve the harder problems,
it will not solve
the harder problems.
Yeah. Oh, were you
raising your hand?
Sorry, I thought this was. Yeah.
>> Is your data also available?
>> Yes, so, the model and the
training needed generators
are all online.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Code is here and
the Arka paper is there.
>> Cool. Okay.
>> Okay. Thank you.